[Aplausos]
comecei a dar os primeiros passos nas
lides artísticas aos três anos de idade
segundo os meus pais me contaram que
fazia disse uma tarefa diária estimate
que levantava e desenhava até me deitar
jogávamos países no ápice guardava
debaixo do travesseiro eu começava no
dia seguinte continuava prefere a minha
mãe dizia não vemos nem na angústia do
meu pai o grande pintor que é uma sumir
viver dar de uma visão da precariedade
lado que essa decisão acarreta porque de
certa forma a gente consegue perceber
que era complicado continuar uma vida
mas no entanto essa essa visão e essa
prática
eu também não deu certa maneira me para
a vida
a mulher foi muito na escola primária de
16 anos 50 em uma escola na época online
de estar divididas em masculino e
feminino
as salas de aula eram divididas em três
filas
os ricos os remediados e os povos ea
professora um dia
chama uma mina da fila dos pobres que
tinha as costas da mão todas cheias de
feridas provocadas pelas freiras em
paralisar ea menina mostra a mão ao
contrário foi um momento pessoal
disparou de volta e até hoje eu
considero que tem uma hipersensibilidade
todas as formas de injustiça e crueldade
que continuam a existir
basta olhar à nossa volta para o mundo
em questão desumanização já docente no
porto então os muros da cidade
palavras de ordem contra a fome contra a
corrupção quando vivemos tempos de
ditadura e foi em priorizar o uso e
combater
dessa forma e retomar a liberdade
claro que obviamente foi preso
era a polícia política o que não diminui
não parece muito mais tardio teve um
exílio político em paris cidade que
transbordava arte cultura e que não seja
cruzeiro em uma vontade enorme de ainda
comunicar mais através da psiquê que
dizia que um dia haveria de salvar o
mundo e eu queria muito que beleza dos
meus quadros fosse dotado toda a força
que fosse capaz para transmitir tudo que
eu pensava
então fui aprendendo com os clássicos da
pintura em tape pinto e conseguir o
domínio da técnica para expressar melhor
conseguir a precisão cirúrgica da figura
humana para ainda transmito tudo muito
melhor
desculpa eu tô indo pra me disse nada
eu me pergunto
[Aplausos]
porque tem muito caro foi foi muita
dureza na minha vida vou passar alguns
exemplos
talvez seja bom para vocês perceberem do
castor salário nos segmentos do que viu
e salvamento
eu queria muito que os meus quadros
transmitir sem induzir 100 no observador
um certo grau na justiça
que beleza transmitida pro casa uma
certa forma de redenção
eu queria muito cuidar das pessoas e de
certa forma o meu trabalho posso me
considerar a valer em 15 um artista da
figura humana é essencialmente uma lista
por exemplo este quadro que pintou um
ano passado que centenas irá transmitir
o drama dos refugiados e que continua
atual
a série mais longa
[Aplausos]
a ser o artista mais longa que fiz ao
longo da minha vida foi pintar mais do
150 tratos que abordavam os rostos dos
muitos dos meus amigos da minha tribo da
fat
estávamos exemplos pensava a cada um
contribui uma cor para tentar transmitir
a essência de cada ser e fui continuando
a pintar nos mais sempre para tentar
incluí los no meu espaço mais sagrado
que é o da arte e para o elemento foi
divulgando os país através de exposições
chamava do elogio do essencial e que
eram expostos como uma película de filme
tentava comunicar e contar histórias do
olhar os que falavam entre si
então o público curiosamente ao longo
deste processo e para minha tristeza ou
era uma vez de tratá-los que nunca não
se interessaram nem quiseram pelos
quadros que eu tinha feito
art
rompendo de para salvar mas não
necessariamente
aliás nunca salvará que não quer sessão
o maior trato que fiz em toda a minha
vida foi feito
numa parede em um lugar numa tela no
antigo edifício do armazém da seca do
bacalhau em vê-lo do quanto se a onda
vitor e na china era um gosto de uma
senhora
[Aplausos]
era um gosto de uma semana das caixinhas
a dona fátima que os 15 anos de idade
lá trabalhou o argumento e eu pretendia
gosto simbolizar a todas as mulheres que
lá trabalharão em homenagem através dela
arthur urbano o cinema muito de
potenciar a solo o artista retira o
quadro da casa ou da galeria e
transforma em patrimônio da rua e eu
queria muito também
nesse processo e de certa forma aquilo
que eu estava fazendo até o momento
era também o retorno o meu início no
fundo esta era a minha palavra de ordem
à semelhança do que tinha feito quando
era jovem e tanto esse passado algum
tempo o rosto lindo gigante daquela
mulher que eu e meu filho tenhamos
pintado com tanta dureza e com tanto
amor acabou por ser censurado
destruído por alguém em durham e que não
sabia de algum lugar
esta foi a minha resposta malvado e a
nova palavra de ordem
o exame a vida inteira que os meus
gestos fosse cultura ética estética ato
não interessa pela decoração arte
interessa me interessam as pessoas ser
pessoas não conseguem explorar rosto dos
outros então proponho que usemos
corações em que no coração simboliza
encontremos urgência sejamos capazes de
ver os quadros de todas as pessoas do
mundo
[Aplausos]